[Music]  good morning parker  [Music]  i really like your photos  oh thanks  uh listen are you busy friday night  [Music]  cool uh can you take pictures of my  boyfriend's car  i just you know i really want to frame a  good one for his birthday  that's really nice you wow that's such a  nice thought um  yeah look at the old uh  your schedule okay  parker  yes sir i'm gonna keep that skateboard  yeah keep it off the ground  wheels up like that  that's it okay  [Music]  having  [Music]  [Applause]  eat your vegetables gordon come on  come on  hey partner come on get a picture  [Applause]  [Music]  hey  come on get up parker  get up come on  come on  still not taking the picture stay down  parker  we want one more  flash  we still on for after school today  my house 3 30. i hope you've been doing  your homework last time i was  very disappointed in you no flash how  about we go to class hmm how about it  whatever  you